chris hogan here i spent a lot of time
on the road speaking with people about
their millionaire success stories you're
about to step into the life of someone
who crossed over to millionaire status
on their own terms what i learned in
childhood was to be afraid of money and
a big part of my story was getting rid
of what I call the poverty mentality I
have a make-do mentality like make do
with what you have it doesn't matter the
clothes on your back it's the person
inside that counts money is a tool but
it doesn't define me my personal
integrity defines me what are the
limitations lie in you and your
surroundings and your circumstances and
what can you change to make a difference
and I still say that everyone if they
live within their means they can do
wonders and that's because they've
refused to accept the status quo
[Music]
a small paycheck in your 20s or your 30s
shouldn't cost you your dream it tests
the goal if it's not worth sacrificing
for then it's not a good enough goal yet
it's the little stuff changing the
habits making new habits when you're not
making very much money at all for
anybody who thinks they want to become a
millionaire but it looks so far off if
you work hard enough to get out of debt
you have the skills that will make you a
millionaire because now you have
millionaire knowledge and you have
millionaire habits you can't help it you
will become a millionaire
we have talked to so many millionaires
this year we've been all over the
country and that tells us something that
people everywhere are taking control of
their money their lives and making it
happen
these people aren't special they're
normal
anyone can become a millionaire and
these people they're the proof
we lived in a kind of remote area of San
Diego County and surrounded by trees and
brush well there's a huge fire that came
to town and we basically had to escape
our house in the middle of flames so I
actually had to drive into the fire you
don't just stop and wait and burn keep
moving forward I think would be a key
and finally success
[Music]
my challenge with a lot of people is
getting them to believe in themselves
you can do it like they said I had to
change my attitudes that I was always
gonna be that farm girl that was wanting
people to love me but you can change we
are all selfish people we're our own
worst enemy at times but if we're
consistent I think we can all get them
money as emotionless money is a tool
that you can use for various things the
point for us isn't that you need to have
one dream the point is that you can
dream in a variety of ways we lived a
lifestyle that fit our dreams and
enabled us to get to the point where we
are today it is possible to live your
dreams and to be excited and to
enthusiast if we pursue life and you
will achieve what you want if you want
it bad enough
[Music]
[Music]
you